now that we know spider-man is sticking
around in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
thanks to the New Deal Sony Disney and
Marvel reached in September 2019 it's
not totally unreasonable to think that
spider-man 3 may feature another major
Avenger while according to an entirely
unconcerned drummer published by we got
this covered that idea might become
reality and by unconfirmed rumor we mean
Internet chatter and by might become
reality we mean nobody actually has any
idea but we can dream right the outlet
cites unnamed sources claiming that the
upcoming spider-man 3 will co-star
another prominent Avenger Captain Marvel
Doctor Strange or MS marvel whom we've
yet to meet on screen here's what we
think let's break this rumor down by
starting with Captain Marvel save for
that awesome endgame scene where Spidey
handed over the iron Infinity Gauntlet
to the Kree powered Captain Peter Parker
and Carol Danvers haven't spent much
time on screen together on the other
hand there is that end credits scene
from spider-man far from home that
featured Talos and Sauron the scroll
couple who first appeared in Captain
Marvel if that mysterious scene was
setting up some sort of Skrulls
storyline for spider-man 3
Captain Marvel will probably want to be
involved in one way or another after all
she's basically their Savior I'll help
you find a home finish what Marvel
started Captain Marvel and spider-man
are also the strongest contenders to be
the face of the MCU now that Iron Man
and Captain America are out of the
picture so having them share the screen
in spider-man 3 could be Disney's way of
ushering in the new era of marvel at the
movies that said Tom Holland and brie
Larson our a-list actors with their own
superhero franchises to focus on so
there's a pretty decent chance that
they'll stick to their own corners of
the MCU and never meet up on screen
again strange is a master of the mystic
arts who deals with metaphysical threats
to our reality spider-man is a friendly
neighborhood hero whose battles are very
grounded they're not exactly a perfect
superhero match that's why it's easy to
forget that Spidey and strange have a
history
they spent some time together during
Avengers infinity war which sought
Peters idea of saving the sorcerer
supreme from ebony ma and the dual
engaging in a bit of banter though we
can't say that strange was overly
friendly towards Spidey
what is he your ward no I'm Peter by the
way Doctor Strange Oh your made-up names
um I'm spider-man then strange is also
based in New York like Spidey so the
odds of the two of them bumping into one
another seems fairly high on the flip
side though the upcoming Doctor Strange
in the multiverse of madness is bringing
another Avenger into the Sorcerer's
Supremes world for a little crossover
action Elizabeth Olsen's Scarlet Witch
the flick is set to launch in theaters
on May 7th 2021 just a few months before
spider-man 3 opens on July 16th 2021
after watching Strange and Scarlet
team-up and Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness audiences may have
a bin there done that attitude to
spider-man 3 if it truly does feature
Doctor Strange if the name Ms marvel
isn't ringing any bells for you that's
because the character hasn't yet
appeared on screen but she will Kamala
Khan the Pakistani American teenager who
can stretch and bend her body into all
sorts of shapes is confirmed a star on
her own upcoming series on the new
streaming service Disney plus a few
years from now if MS Marvel doesn't
premiere until 2022 the character could
first appear in spider-man 3
on one hand MS Marvel debuting in
spider-man 3 might make sense Kamala is
around the same age as Peter and since
the MCU has no other teen heroes it
would be great to see the two share the
screen together on the other hand it
might be a horrible decision the House
of Heroes rarely makes mistakes when it
comes to introducing characters into its
mammoth franchise that spans film and
now television and having Kamala Khan
take her first turn on the screen in
someone else's movie could be a massive
misstep that Rob's the young hero of her
own proper debut
regardless of whether any of these
Avengers or any Avengers at all will
join Peter Parker and spider-man three
Disney and Marvel clearly don't plan on
losing spider-man anytime soon
spider-man 3 could be one big Avengers
reunion or it could be strictly centered
around Spidey himself either way the
film is sure to be a smash when it
swings into theaters on July 16 2021
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you